hey guys pete here i'm gonna try this
again
this will be the live stream for the
expanse season six episode three
it's a chance to take a deeper look at
the episode and get into some things
that i don't get a chance to look at in
my recap you know take a closer look
dig deeper have a discussion and
hopefully answer some questions from the
chat
i'm joined again today by benja from
ben2tv channel you want to say hello
hi guys good to be here again
and we're going to be talking all we're
going to be talking about all things
expanse we'll get into the episode force
projection
the book that shows based on babylon's
ashes
and the x-ray episode win or lose but we
won't be giving away any spoilers beyond
this episode episode three
and i think we can jump right into it
from there why don't we start with the
amos and bobby mini episode
yeah this one was titled win or lose
this is one of the x-ray episodes
uh this one also starts with a
a voiceover as amy says doctrine of one
ship in compet
encompasses both tension and resolution
and bobby goes
with no favor to either
conflict and acceptance unified into
something greater
we had these quotes at every single at
the beginning of every single
episode of these x-ray episodes
and what do you think about this one
pete
well as far as the the the quote
i find these pretty fascinating because
this doctrine of the one ship is like
the belter thing you know and so it's
interesting to see different things how
they're applying that to these different
characters i'm not exactly sure where
they're going with it still
but as far as the x-ray scene overall
i think this is the best kind of fan
service you know what i mean like you
can't go wrong you put these two
characters in a room together and
i thought that this was probably the
best one even though
it contributed the least to actually
what was going on in the story you know
what i mean
yeah and
to you know to explain the scene a
little bit because people might not have
seen it since it's an it's a bonus
episode
amos and bobby are cleaning up to cargo
hold and uh they have they have a back
and forth they're mad they're messing
with each other
they both get in some good ones and it
escalates to a challenge because you
know both of these characters are alphas
bobby suggests a simple game
first one who hits the deck loses and
the loser has to clean up the rest by
themselves
so it's like a little wager
james says let's go let's go over the
rules sorry and
he does this to distract bobby
and he makes his move but you know bobby
you know you know her
she
she doesn't she doesn't buy it
she easily puts him into a sleeper hold
and starts chalking him out
amos looks like he's gonna just pass out
he struggles but he's eventually able to
get out his hand terminal to set off an
alarm that causes
bobby to let go because she is
distracted
which is how amos slams bobby to the
floor and wins
and i thought that was just
yeah i noticed that wes chatham had a
writing credit here and
i think he came up with this ending
himself what do you think
yeah they they mentioned this they
talked about it a little bit on the last
podcast i think is where i heard that
and um
it's cool that they gave him that chance
you know he's definitely interested in
writing he does the podcast with tai and
yeah i think that it was i think that
you could kind of you can kind of see
that it's a little bit different and
it's kind of in his voice as the
character
i thought there was a great a lot of
great little lines here and
i really like the idea of
them
you know they're saying things that to
anyone else you know that would be
completely crossing the line you know
but they're just sort of testing each
other and they let it they let it go
until they find this
idea you know to where they can actually
make it count you know i mean who can
get who to the ground or whatever
and um
i think my favorite line was
when she's telling him hey don't worry
it's going to be over soon and she says
it's almost nappy time i think that's
probably my favorite
but the um the remember when the earth
had a blue sky and he comes back
remember when when mars had two moons
i liked how they are casually mentioning
details
from the early episodes in the early
seasons in their conversations
she says you know the donnie here and
earlier they talk or later in the
episode they talk about the cant and
that two moons quote i remember that
scene whenever she first came onto the
rossi back in season three
whenever she you know she comes she
brings uh alva sarala in and she's
injured
and a little bit later she realizes that
somebody messed with the flag and of
course we know that was amos so
i thought that was just those little
things that are in the dialogue they're
totally natural
it's not like hey remember remember this
when this happened
but but you know it's great at the end
of a you know final season of a show
where all of that stuff is already in
your mind and they can pull on those
little things to
add a little bit to everything you know
yeah and i think it's all this scene
also shows how far bobby has come
because as you pointed out earlier in
the series
in season three and in earlier seasons
bobby was
you know the the perfect martian soldier
but um she has become disillusioned with
the martian army and the planet in
general
and she can take a joke now because
can you even imagine
what would happen if amos made the made
these kinds of jokes
back in season three
there would be a real fight that time
around
yeah it would yeah
she would have come a deer she would
have commandeered the ship which she
already thought was
stolen from the martians in the first
place and she would have been driving it
back with them all hog tied in the cargo
hold for sure
and when you compare this x-ray episode
to the first two
where do you put it i think this one
what this one is my favorite because it
was so much different than the
than the actual episodes
but what do you think
yeah i think that it would be hard i
think that's my favorite so far and also
that it'll be hard to top
i don't know how they'll you know where
i think where you go from here but
i mean like i said i think what what's
cool about it is that it's a little bit
different in that it's just
fun you know what i mean
it's not that consequential it's just
three
however many minutes long it was of
two great characters
making you remember the journey that
they were on to get where they're at and
you know doing something that's
completely entertaining
yeah like i said last week these feel
like extra scenes or deleted scenes from
dvds
so i always like those i always you know
watch those after i finish the season
uh
and
you know this is this is like a nice
it's like a nice flashback
i think we can move on to laconia
because the episode opens up with a
close-up look at the orbital orbital
platforms as i draw as a drop shuttle
returns to the planet
i couldn't really figure out um
where that drop shuttle was
coming from to be honest and what that
orbital platform was do you have any um
insight into that
yeah well i mean for the non-spoiler
the non-spoiler
explanation
there
this is something that's in orbit around
the planet laconia
they knew it was there before they
chose this system
and we see this this is the one we see
um
at the start of the season right
yeah
we saw it for the first time
on the ship whenever uh
what's his name
was it
cortazar
was was looking talking to them on the
ship you could see it in the in the sky
in the background
and then you saw it in the closing
credits
so in the beginning you're just seeing
it from the you're seeing a shuttle
leaving that going back down to the
planet's surface
someone was visiting the platform doing
something you have no idea what it was
but you know they're going back down to
the planet at this point
yeah and then we see you know this scene
right here there's a classroom with a
martian soldier talking to the kids
he makes a pretty clear distinction
between the survey group who was already
at the planets before they arrived
but kara's family was a part of this
and then there was the group from mars
that came after he says he says that the
people have been there longer can help
those who arrived after by telling them
if they notice anything different then
as we know kara has noticed
something different the strange dog
so
cara is looking at
looking at her device looking at looking
up how to keep the baby sunbirds alive
and
the soldier notices this and approaches
cara so what did you think about this
scene and what do you think about this
distinction between the two groups at
this planet on this planet
i think that as far as the distinction
is i think that's one of the things you
need to
pay attention to um
they're mentioning it for a reason i
guess so
whenever
whenever the
what what happened at the end of season
five is
that pretty much all of the martian
breakaway fleet except for the bar keith
made it through the ring gate
and transited to the laconia system so
all of that martian military and all of
that personnel
went through and these people cara's
family and the group that she was with
they're all scientists they were there
and you heard in the last episode when
they were talking
about the relays like basically they
shut everything down
so now these people are
living on this planet and
these soldiers came over came in and
took it over and they don't really have
a choice you know what are they going to
do they can't they have no power in the
situation
and so
the distinction with that is that
this is you know this is an occupied
planet now that they happen to be on
and they don't really have any say in
how things go from here and they can't
talk back to you know they can't get a
hold of earth
the the relays are turned down or turned
off so
it's kind of a messed up situation for
them
yeah what's especially messed up is uh
this martian guy talking to
these kids without their parents present
because i guess he's like their
teacher i don't know what's going on
here i don't know if this is i think
it's
i think that's the you know that's the
what they're trying to show is that
they're just taking over now it's you go
to school you go to martian soldier
school
you know
yeah and another kid going to school is
zan is that is that how you say his name
cara's yes zan like alexander yeah yeah
zan is going to play sucker soccer after
school i want to say football i this
this word is foreign to me
really
cara is thinking about the birds and
tells him to stop following her because
you know
diana has been really curious about what
kara's been up to
and when kara returns to the glade she
finds the drone which was broken
and now realizes it's been fixed what
could have done this few things
and as she activates the drone she hears
the strange dog
and sees that it's watching her
then she hears the mother bird who is
again taking care of her babies and she
says you fixed her you know
she says this to the strange dog
apparently is this
this strange dog is
a magical creature i'm not saying
magical literally but you know it's
fixed a living thing and also the drone
i think this is
one of the best moments of the season so
far because
i've been wondering where this
laconia storyline was going and
apparently this
magical creature
can fix things you know the implications
of this are massive
i suppose you know a lot more about this
than you can
really discuss here but um how did this
moment feel for you when you were yes
when you saw
kara realize what the strange dogs were
capable of
i thought
i thought they handled it pretty well i
i thought that it was
like i said this is a mysterious book in
in the way that it's you don't really
know anything that's going on
so it's a little tough to add like to
adapt it in the beginning of every
episode because people wonder where is
it going so now we kind of hit the point
of
everything set up
and now you can see and you can what i
like about this whole
situation
is it's from the perspective
of an eight-year-old kid
you know if an adult sees something like
this the you know the they're gonna
think about it totally in a different
way
and
it's funny because a lot of people have
been saying in the in the comments and
things like why are these kids allowed
to just run around on this planet and
i never even thought about that when i
read the book just you know i figured
they're on this planet there's not that
many people here
she goes out to play like i did when i
was a kid or whatever it just happens to
be on this thing but um
yeah i think what's really interesting
is the fact that it comes down through
an eight-year-old kid's eyes the you
know she's the one that experiences this
and you know the soldier asked have you
been noticing something that's been
happening especially
in the last few weeks and so
i think you can put it together that
what he's talking about there is he's
talking about
the since they brought the
proto-molecule through the ring gate
you know what i mean they're wondering
because
you remember back well obviously you
remember what happened in season four
when they went to ellis but you will
remember that in the in the whenever
alex and lieutenant babbage went out for
dinner
he thought they were going to like hook
up or whatever he's all interested in
her but the only thing she wanted to pay
attention to was what happened when they
brought that proto-molecule to illus
so i thought you know those are the kind
of things that
are
what should be standing out at this
point
and
i wanted to ask a non-book reader here
like what are you starting to put
together like is there a theory going on
obviously you said this one felt like it
was one of the better but is this where
where do you think this is all going now
that since you have no idea
i i mean it's quite hard to figure out
figure it out but um
it's obviously got some either healing
powers or i'm not sure if it if it's got
healing powers or if it turns these
creatures or devices into
something else if they become a hybrid
of sorts i'm not sure about that part
yet so this mother bird the strange dog
fixed
is not the same it's got some different
parts
so apparently yeah you could you could
see that much from just what you can see
on the on the screen right yeah exactly
and
that's why i'm still curious about where
they're gonna go with this
because
if this was just a magical process where
they were resurrected that would be
that would be really weird but you know
this
this other stuff this um stuff on the on
the bird and that fascinates me because
i want i want to immediately see how the
strange dog does it
i could just pick up the books and read
but i'm going to i'm going to be patient
and
see how it turns out on the show i guess
ask
if you think they will
show this process on the show
or if they're going to leave it for a
possible future series or movie
um well yeah it's not something that
it becomes apparent by the end of the
strange dog's book
like it's one of those things where
you know
you as you as you correctly guessed it's
not magic there's no magic involved this
is this is still
the expanse universe so it is
something that you'll understand
why that's why it's happening i guess
but not
how it happens
i think that's the best that i could say
about that and i wanted to mention this
super chat that we had here
tm martin esquire thank you for the
super chat
hello
how would you rank this season 6 episode
3 battle scene compared to the entire
series so far
so it's a little bit of a
divergence but
i'm not really big on ranking things in
general
i um
it's one of those things that i kind of
i i have a real recency bias with just
about and whatever i just watched is
usually the thing that i like the best
if i'm being honest so you know what i
mean
i think technically it was amazing
i think as far as and i thought about
this because a lot of people have been
talking about it
i still think the one that knocked my
socks off the most was
the thoth station raid whenever they go
against the um
stealth ship this was this looks better
in
many ways but
that was sort of the first one that
really i was like wow this is you know
this show is actually
serious about thinking about how this
stuff works and they really pulled that
off
what did you think
i'm like you because i'm not big on
re-watching shows especially if they're
not sci-fi shows so i watched i
rewatched the expanse because it is a
sci-fi show
normally i don't
and
i think i re-watched the expanse only
once or maybe twice i might have watched
the first two first three seasons two
times but anyway um
i
i'm not sure how to
rank these really because like you said
there are different types of encounters
here it's three on one so
the stakes are a little bit higher
because it is also marco
and
ali alex is not here alden has to
command the ship while this is going on
he has to pilot the ship so
in that regard
this was better than i expected
especially when you know the ship
i don't know how to say it it just kind
of aim locked like like in the games it
was like a 360 noscope
i didn't really know how how else to
describe it
and that moment was incredible when they
were using their guns but
uh yes and so
people have been calling it the 360 no
scope for as long as i can remember i'm
not a gamer so that's not a term that i
would use like i tried not to co-op that
whenever i talked about it because i
really
i understand it like i i heard people
calling it i looked it up and then i was
like oh that's cool but i don't really
i've never done one myself so you know
what i mean i i don't feel comfortable
describing it that way
but yeah i think
um
i think that
generally speaking that they have gotten
better
at all things as far as how they put the
show together i think craft wise
they've just they've had a pretty
consistent increase in quality so i
think on that level
it's great
in the context of the story
we'll we'll get into that later
and
i think i still i think if i had to i
mean i think the ones at the end of last
season were really good
there's been a ton of them
i mean
i think that the the thoth station one
just because it was the first that
really grabbed me in that way is
probably my favorite
um
sequence like that
and that's where that's what i would say
if i had to
make a definitive list
looks like we have another one here so
let's look at this right away this one
is from made in brooklyn 1975.
my theory is
she cara will want to use the strange
dog to revive her brother and he could
become a proto-molecule hybrid person
yes we haven't mentioned this yet so um
when cara comes back home
she's all excited to tell her parents
about what happened but she learns that
her brother zan was killed in an
accident
so
that's just the b this is that's an
incredible coincidence right
carol discovers something that can fix
things and
her brother dies
it does seem it does seem well timed
speaking
i i did like how they they foreshadowed
that
it's dangerous there now that the
soldiers are there right she's she
almost got hit by the golf cart jeep
kind of thing that was going through
there
so
i think that this uh i think made in
brooklyn 1975 is probably
on to something
i wouldn't say that
i don't know about um
any of the details involved but i get
the i get where they're coming from and
thinking that there might be
some connection there yeah my guess is
my guess is you know the hybrid bit the
high
it could be a hybrid but
i don't think pr the prior molecule will
be involved in this particular storyline
i don't have anything to base that off
but that's just the feeling i get right
now
yeah i mean the hybrid is the total the
hybrids from project caliban from you
know season two
early part of season three that's a
that's a whole different process of
course
yeah
i'm not measuring i'm not saying the
hybrid in that sense not a product
molecule hybrid it may be a different
kind of hybrid
right right yeah because i was just i
was just pointing out that like when
someone gets infected with the proto
molecule they turn into one of those
zombies
that spreads it to other people
you know the the the hybrids the ones
that we saw that were weaponized that
was a different process where
they were in it was introduced to them
and it sort of
started to take over their physiology
but
they weren't infected in the same way
that that regular people were
all right i think we can move on to
series
the united united the united fleet of
the united nations of earth and luna and
the martian congressional republic navy
have arrived at ceres
they were expecting a fight
but
no free navy ships were there the
station was abandoned by marco and
company
and
mcr incrino says
it feels like a trap and amazon
acknowledges that they're already in it
so
krino returned i don't know how to say
her name either give you guys some weird
names here but
um she has returned i think she was in
season three
and
she she's with avasarala in the scene i
wanted to ask how you felt about
the plan marco came up with you know i
was like i was expecting a full-blown
war here
where the free navy would defend the
station a little bit before running away
i never thought he would stay marco
would stay there forever but i thought
there would at least be a confrontation
but the plan michael came up with was a
lot was a lot better than i thought how
do you how do you feel about this move
you know
well i think that
for i mean i think he only had so many
choices
i think it is probably the best choice
for him to make it's a it's interesting
it's it's a it's a great part of the
story because you have like moral
implications that we see with
philip how he feels about it
you have
tactical
of course this does make them look bad
but he is giving up a lot
you know what i mean he has like series
is an important place
in the belt
so
i think that i think what's best about
this whole thing is that it
manages to get you to think about all
those different things like
did he make the right choice
i think yes probably
should he have done it
i mean
that's where it starts to get
interesting right
i mean from from a strategic standpoint
i think he should have done it i i am
completely behind marcus decision here
from you know not from a humanitarian
standpoint but
he's in a war and he knows he can't feed
um ceres
they haven't got enough supplies or
they've got supplies but he doesn't want
to give it to them
so i thought you know running away was
the best option because
he made series um the interest problem
i think that was really true
yeah i i think yeah i think that there's
there's definitely an argument to me
made for it
um
so they locate the people who are all
together and
nico sanjirani the station chief says
they're the chief administrator and
they'll talk someone who matters
and also i talked to sanjirani on a
video called feed so masarala doesn't go
into the station which is just smart you
know i was kind of surprised that was
this close to the action anyway i'm sure
he's i'm sure her ship wasn't you know
uh that close to ceres but
now what did you think about that were
you expecting a vasala to um
appear here
i'm not really sure what to make of it i
mean it seems to me that seems kind of
crazy right um
i kind of understand where they might
have had the idea that
she has to be close because there's not
faster than light communication
so
you know it's tactically for
not necessarily not necessarily
abasarala but obviously high command
have to be somewhere nearby if they have
to make decisions
so i guess they could kind of
explain it that way
i was surprised that
you know monica goes on to series like
goes on to the station later in the
episode so i was surprised when i saw
that that they were that close that she
can just hop on a shuttle
i thought maybe that uh you know
avastarala might be somewhere
tucked away from the station or whatever
you know what i mean but it kind of
makes it feel like they're right in the
general vicinity
and i you know i think it's
it's probably a show thing that they had
you know they wanted to keep people
close together for some reason but i
think you could probably explain it by
the communication delay
that if they thought there was going to
be a resistance right whenever they
showed up if they were going to have to
be dealing with something in real time
then they would need to have
admiral siddiqui and i guess it's
admiral carino now it looks like she's
been raised in her rank at the mcrn
they would have to be close by so that
they could coordinate that
avocado is just avastarala so you want
to be
you know you want her to be there
because she drives uh the
action the story there
um yeah and also is usually the star
whenever she's in a scene she steals the
show but um in her conversation with
sanjirani i thought sandrani was great
especially the bit about
you know
um
when um
buenos aires asked why sangrani was not
working for the man who assassinated
those
then johnny goes i work for the belt i
thought that was a that was a great
moment
and yeah
tanjani overall was
just great in this
i wasn't convinced i wasn't really that
interested in the earlier episodes in in
sundrani but here i i really liked her
i think that's part of the problem with
the the you know with the faster
pace is these characters rosenfeld
sandrani
the guy who is with uh avasarala in some
of her scenes i just figured out his
name is gareth from the x-ray
the casting thing
there's really not much time to develop
them so i thought that this was where
you kind of get the idea of who this
character is why they're important for
the story and i thought it worked pretty
well
i just i would like to have had more
backstory if i'm being honest though um
obviously it's character that
plays a role in the book
it's a little bit different on the tv
show
but as you said this was their moment
you know i work for the belt and that is
the
that is the whole
that's the whole thing about this you
know i mean that's the whole thing about
all these characters
they're damned if they do and they're
damned if they don't it's the same with
uh drummer and her people and you know
it's
there's no real there's no there's no
good out and for her for that you know
this
sandrani character
they made the choice to stay even though
they know that there's going to be this
interrogation they could be imprisoned
it's it's i thought it yeah i think that
this was a
a great episode for this character
i just want to take a second to look at
the uh
this this here from 88th bus stop super
chat thank you for the super chat
someone alluded to holden looking
somewhat unhealthy and suggesting that
cancer could have been the reason the
show will be paused
i haven't heard anything about that
i did hear something but i i heard that
he he lost some weight and he tried to
look
like the like what the character was
going through but i can't confirm that i
only heard it second hand what did you
think about that did you think it was
noticeable that holden looked
physically different
it's definite
yeah it's definitely noticeable and
i've heard you know i've read from the
greatest source on the world the
internet
that um
he lost weight on purpose like you said
no reason to doubt that at all
anyway
i think um
holden definitely looks different this
season he's always been a little bit
lean i think
but because they've been out out in
space for
close to 200 days now
um they might have
they might have wanted to make him look
this way to
to display this trace to display the
stress he's under
i think that i think that's reasonable
yeah
that was my take when i watched it i i
thought they all looked pretty haggard
and that was the way that they showed it
with him
it didn't stand out to me as being
dramatic i thought they all looked
really kind of beat down especially in
the first episode
and it just seemed like part of it to me
but i have heard a lot of people bring
that up so
i definitely haven't heard anything
about cancer that that's not something
that i've heard at all so thanks for
that question and we have one other one
here from
in brooklyn 1975
marco didn't just run away in dessert
series he went the extra mile to
sabotage series and plant bombs that
could kill belters and inners alike
we will get to the
the bombs that went off we'll get to
that later but
i don't think at this point we know
what happened with that
it's not really clear
if they if if he left that behind or if
that's something that
there's like organic resistance to them
being there for the people who's still
there's still a million people that live
on ceres
some of them will
some of them would naturally be
resistant to any occupation
but i do think that's important i think
i think made in brooklyn brings up an
important point though that
he took everything of value before he
left and he did leave them
with
a in a much worse situation than when he
arrived so
we didn't really touch on that when we
were talking about the decision that he
made what do you think about that part
of his decision
yeah i mean that is to be expected from
marco i think um
the
the people there only have a
they can only supply a million people on
three weeks notice so
you know they they've they've got
food and air for only three more weeks
so
they're gonna they're gonna die off if
the u.n and
the
the martians don't help them
and
it's cruel for sure
but this is what i expect from marco
and he touches on this later on in the
episode
while he was talking to philip about how
people at the series station
aren't really belters
he doesn't see them as you know real
hardcore belters i guess
and we'll talk more about that
later on and later on in the show
yeah um yes hopefully you can stay
stick around made in brooklyn because we
will be talking about that a little bit
more later because that's a big part of
what happens between him and his son so
thanks for the super chat and
one other thing i just have to bring up
is the
reminder that dawes is dead that's a
bummer
when you hear that again in this episode
um i was reading the book again the
other day and i got to the the chapters
there's a couple of dolls chapters there
and that's one of the things i'm really
missing from from the season
is that part of the story so
it's it's definitely
it's definitely sad that they didn't
it's definitely not sad it's frustrating
that they couldn't
incorporate this character a little bit
in seasons five and six because
this point that abu sarah makes is
you know it really underlines it when
you think about dawes was a bad guy
you know relative to fred johnson in the
eyes of the inners right and so
i like the how she made that distinction
you used to work for dawes who was
reasonable you know he was an okay guy
we could work with him
how are you working with marco and it's
like they don't really have a choice
what do you do if you don't work with
marco
you get thrown out an airlock right so
it's either that or your ship gets blown
off or your station
yeah we saw that everybody who went
against him had you know we saw in
season five whenever drummer was out
there scavenging
she found the ships of the person that
voted against him
you know in whenever they had that trial
on the tynan in season four so
you know if anything he's going after it
so
roz gray says that he ain't dead he's
promoted to harry selden
yeah he's he's
uh what's his name jared harris is still
out there he's still out there for us to
enjoy i just would have loved to see a
little bit more of him in in the expanse
but i i think it's you know totally
understandable that
he wasn't he wasn't a series regular and
it's hard to keep them and that kind of
makes you worry about future adaptations
doesn't it like when you think people
people are like oh they'll just quit for
five years and come back with another
three books or whatever yeah it's really
hard whenever when you don't have
you don't have main actors on you know
on contract to actually
put a whole cast together like that
we have no idea what these actors are
gonna do in five years and if they want
to bring the series back they could just
be
on a new popular show not even one of
them maybe
three of them will be in a big show so
they can't come back to the expense
and that's why the break kind of sucks
yeah let's let's get back into
yeah the rossi now
all right
so after the azure dragon after taking
care of that problem they're on route to
series and we have a
we have an interesting moment between
holden and clarissa
they've been a good duo this season
so i wanted to ask your opinion on this
scene
and
you know ask if clarissa becomes a part
of the crew in the books as well or is
this is this um just a show thing
because
they're kind of getting really close
here
holden and clarissa nolden really seems
to care about her now
yeah clarissa does become a permanent
part of the crew in in much the same way
the big difference in the books is that
holden is the one who really has a hard
time with it
in the show they made that in the first
couple of episodes they gave that to
naomi
and they sort of switched the thing
where naomi was
she was kind of obsessed with the bar
keith going missing
and
holden was kind of obsessed that they
had clarissa a murderer on the ship
and they sort of flipped those things
back and forth and you kind of
understand that after this episode why
they made that decision because
holden
introduces the idea of the ships going
missing to
um naomi because she's going through
something and he knows if she works on a
project that it'll make her feel better
but
clarissa i i mean
there's the part here where he he's
trying to just
make it right with the crew as is as
they're there not really
personal to her you know what i mean
and
it comes up about her mods and that it's
taking longer for her to recover from it
and then she goes into her her whole
thing about talking about how she got
them because of him
and
what's interesting is that you know he
says
everyone on this ship has something they
regret including amos i think
and that she's in good company and
that's where that's left
but clarissa is a great character
because
of the way that things played out you
know just the circumstances of her
situation
because what she did is in a different
league compared to everyone else on the
rossi yeah they've killed people and
stuff like that but
she
there's a good there's a good argument
to be made that if people end up in
prison for things that what she did
that's like something that you get a
life sentence for you know what i mean
and maybe maybe even a death sentence if
she was a martial absolutely i mean she
blew up a ship she killed people in cold
blood she
could have caused way more i mean
the one redeeming factor of all of it is
that at the end
she actually saves everybody
on you know on the uh behemoth but
you know i think that she's i think
what's really in i mean not to drag it
out but what i think what's really
interesting about her character and
what's funny about it is that
because amos thinks she's okay
and because as fans we like amos
it seems reasonable
do you know what i mean like it seems
reasonable to have her there and if he's
if he likes her then how bad can she be
you know what i mean
yeah but i'm thinking about it you know
how i would react if i was on that ship
and
i'm not sure i would be okay with it you
know
even if amy still liked her i mean i i
don't think i would be okay with it
maybe if alex was here he would have an
objection but
unfortunately that's not gonna happen
yeah like i said i think what what if
you really think about her story the way
that the circumstances played out
it's hard to fault amos for
as the earth is is falling apart and
she's trapped underground they're
trapped underground together
it's hard to fault him for bringing her
along you know what i mean
yeah and and what i would what what just
the last thing i want to say because i
don't want to go too far into that but
the thing with clarissa is she never
forgives herself and she never thinks
that she should be a part of the crew
or that anyone should be all right with
it she if you said to her in your
situation that you just described that
you wouldn't be all right with it she
would agree with you
that's the internal thoughts of clarissa
mal is that she doesn't deserve to
have another chance she does deserve to
be
trapped underground for the rest of her
life and
that's really underlined by the fact
that amos gave her the chance to take
her life before she went in there but
she didn't think that she deserved the
easy way out and you know that's that's
an interpretation obviously but
she had the chance to
space herself and
just end it all and
there's there's a part of her character
that wants to
try to atone but knows that they never
can
yeah and that's what that's what make
that's what makes these stories
interesting isn't it i mean if these
were perfectly normal people
would we would we be watching
so from a from a dramatic standpoint
clarissa
is one of the best characters on the
show
that was the reasons you outlined
we got another super chat here from 88th
bus stop
did dawes betray julie mao because he
never believed an earth or can truly
become a belter
that was a long time to ignore
a mission distress call
i i don't
i think dawes is
this is a little bit difficult to answer
because i've read that book more
recently than i've watched that season
of the show and they're not it doesn't
play out exactly the same way
i think that
the thing to remember with dawes is
he's resourceful and he is
pragmatic in the sense that
he would have to
he would look at things in this he with
with julie and and going after her and
trying to save her at that time it's my
impression that
it would be because she's an earther
it's not it's not like he's he's saying
in
black and white terms and earther can
never truly be an ally to the belt i
mean he brought fred johnson in and
that that sort of stuff he he does
things that that you know that
earthers are different
but
that doesn't mean they can't be useful
for the cause
i think that's a human thing though
where
if you if it's not going well and you
have to look at you're assessing the
situation you have to make a decision
maybe if it was a belter
in that same position he would have
acted different
but i think it's i think it's i don't
think it's as black and white as that as
as what you're saying their 88th bus
stop
but thank you for the
question do you have anything to are you
do you have anything to add on that
not really but
from what i can remember dolls was
using julia mile julie martin when she
became
i suppose a liability
that's why he stopped that's why he
didn't help her that's i'm not sure i'm
not sure about the details
but that's the impression i got
yeah i think like i said it's it's a lot
that's a that's a there's a whole thing
to go into that's kind of unrelated to
where this episode but
yeah if i think of something more to add
to it i definitely will
okay i think we can continue with bobby
and amos they had more than just that
x-ray episode because
uh they talked about food on the ship
which which is just terrible in their
opinion
and they um
they reference the canterbury here
also the dani and
you know there's a nice back and forth
yep
you know that this was just a nice scene
i i'm not sure how consequential it'll
be but
you know i wouldn't mind watching like a
20-minute sitcom or a rom-com between
bobby and amy's on the ship i mean
some of these scenes are just
electric
yeah i i agree and i think we already
touched on what i really liked about
this you know and i think that
it's just another place to point out
that the food that they're eating right
now is bad because
of this war
you know so it's another one of those
little details that are thrown in there
that
you know you that just kind of add to
the situation without saying something
you know add to the atmosphere i guess
without
explicitly saying you know
man times are really tough ever since
the free navy took over and threw those
rocks at earth you know what i mean yeah
so but yeah i think
like i said we touched on this after the
x-ray but their their their whole back
and forth is littered with those
references to earlier episodes and like
you said they're just great playing off
each other so
great scene all the way around
yeah this food business also relates to
what we'll talk talk about next because
naomi's watching a news feed where one
pundit says it's a win that they've
regained control of ceres
but the other one questions how much of
their food is going to support the
belter quantum code terrorists
and i think this was an interesting
segment
um
because absolutely
go on
i was just going to say i i really liked
i i brought this up in the recap so i
won't go too into it that much but it's
just
i liked how they tied all of like the
regular people's experience
the reaction of it the reaction to the
events and how people are seeing it
through those different filters that
people have in their you know in their
way that they consume
information and
i um
you know it's
it it does add it it is another layer to
what
they have to deal with because of
marco's decision right like they can't
feed the people on earth
now they have all these people out here
they have to deal with so
i liked how they kind of
pointed that out through the
um the news feed what naomi was watching
exactly i mean these little details and
clips definitely make the world feel
more realistic
and um
when naomi's watching this new segment
holden comes in to ask her about what
happened when she froze up during the
mission
clarissa had to take over and
naomi kind of feels humiliated because
of this
because she feels like she'll let the
team down and she was having flashbacks
to the pela and chatsumaka
so um holden has the perfect solution
for this he changes the subject and asks
for a favor by bringing up the bar keith
he tells her about the data he got about
the other missing ships from bobby
and um
naomi knows what holden's trying to do
and you know this was this was an
interesting scene as well because
you come at you come to a point at
certain
you come to a certain point in some
relationships where your partner
realizes your
ulterior motive at all times and this
was one of those moments
i thought it was i thought it was really
cute
yeah absolutely i really loved the
relationship stuff that they added i
mean it's always been there but i think
in season six it was my feeling that
this was
peak naomi and holden like they really
the whole idea they've been together for
years on this ship now they've been
through a lot
they understand each other it's
necessary to
work together and to be in a
relationship together and
that that comes because you have their
points of you know you have their
internal thoughts in the books there's a
lot of that that that that's obvious
there but i thought they did a really
good job of bringing that out like
holden you know in the last episode and
the azure dragon he said
you know okay whenever she said that she
wasn't ready to talk about it so he
waits for a while he shows up here
and then
he has a plan on
yeah he wants something he needs
something but
like in any relationship
he does it he you know he approaches
this in a way that is beneficial for her
and
not only that but she gets it you know
they know each other well enough that
she's like oh i see what you're doing
okay
i'm glad you're here you know thank you
for being you you know i mean so it's
cool
we have another quick
super chat here from tm martin again
what do you make of that comment
walker made to drummer about
intimidating marco sexually
uh
do you have anything that you can
i think we talked about this uh
last week as well and
you know walker cracks me up he reminds
me of ashford in that regard we um i
think we mentioned that and
there's definitely some room for fan
fiction here
i'm not going to say much more than that
yeah i think that um
i think that it was supposed to be
mysterio like it's it's something it's
one of those lines that it's funny just
because
someone
went inside their mind and put these
words together and thought that was
something that needed to be
presented
in the first few minutes of talking to
people you know like he's never met
michio who's going into his care
never met joseph
has a has a you know uh
they know each other him and drummer but
it doesn't seem like they're that close
or whatever you know what i mean
so i think it's supposed to be like that
like it has pure
comedic value but then at the same time
you wonder why why why would he do that
you know if you look at the two people
marco is i think
you know
pretty much if you had the shoes you
would pick marco as far as you know
physical
beauty
yeah but
i guess that's why walker is so funny he
needs to be yeah yeah
yeah i think i think it's just like a
great thing i imagine you know when
you're writing
this in a group with a bunch of people
in a what in a writer's room then
it's one of those things that come up
and you can't you can't let it go once
it's once it's out in the world you have
to share it you know
yeah
thanks again for that
so where were we at we're talking
naomi and
yeah i mean hold and then i think we can
move on to the pillar if you'd like well
i i did want to ask you as a
as a non-book reader
what do you think is going he's bringing
up he's really pushing this idea of the
bar keith going missing
we did learn that he does have that data
from the other missing ships from bobby
he got that from mars
and what does this look like to someone
who's never read the books like what do
you expect is going to come out of this
and the other thing i wanted to ask
about it is that
he mentions that he might know somebody
who would know more about this
whenever they're talking so who do you
think that character might be
i think that character is lv okoye from
season four
because uh she dealt with um the the
protomolecule destroyers
more than um alden did i think you went
to she went into that artifact didn't
she
i think that's definitely alveolar dr
elliot
i'm pretty sure
that's gonna turn out to be her
uh solid reasoning there i would say
um i'm trying to remember the other part
of your question sorry
um oh the bar keith the ship's going
missing why do you think this is
important
i mean obviously
obviously they're they're trying to keep
this
um prana molecule and paramount you
destroy your civilization storyline
relevance but because i know this season
only this season is only six episodes
and we're not gonna get more than that
at least for the foreseeable future
i don't think we're going to get a
satisfying
payoff payoff in this storyline
if anything we're just going to get
some tidbits
so i really can't get
that excited about what i'm seeing on
this front to be perfectly honest
fair enough
if i knew the show was going to continue
i would still be
really excited for it because
like i said countless times
this stuff
is um the main reason why i like the
expense it's one of the main reasons
let's say
and by right now it just feels like
a side story that's going to give us
some
some tidbits and
that's all
uh yeah like i said that's sound that's
sound reasoning we can probably go on
over to the pellet now
right at the pellet on the pellet philip
is watching news feeds where he sees
that the decision to flee siri station
is being re be not being received well
by the welt by the belt
and
once again
these new new segments are playing an
important role
in um
in
in that we are you know seeing these
characters react to what's going on on
the
other side of the soul system and
i think that's a great addition this
season
and
what do you think about this you know
what do you think about philip
feeling down
because um they're now being perceived
as heroes on the contrary they're being
you know their reputation is in tatters
what do you think about that
i think it's a perfect i think it's the
perfect
thing
it's a perfect external thing to
really just bring out what's going on
inside of his head anyways you know in
different ways like with his mother with
his father
he has these feelings and then he has
the reality and so what's you know with
this idea of
people not starting to lose
uh their
admiration for the free navy as things
start to get bad as they are going to
always do whenever there's a war going
on
it i think it's a nice parallel to
what's like i said the outside and the
inside what his father says and what his
father does
how he feels about his father how he
thinks he should perform how he should
be who the person he feels like he is
the person he feels like he needs to be
as a part of you know this
military operation or whatever
so yeah i i again we mentioned it before
i don't need to
go on about it so much but the the news
feeds as the way in is is great here and
i really like
like like a lot happens with philip in
this episode
i mean a lot happens overall but for his
story in general like it has a couple
twists and turns
you know what i mean
so
i feel like this is a great little spot
to establish where he's at because
things are going to change pretty
quickly
yeah and philip has a one-on-one
conversation with his father
and marco here says
you know people over it over on series
are soft and they're dependent on their
comforts
that was definitely an interesting
comment
and marco gosco you and i we are meant
to be out here in the darkness in the
fight
that's who we are
who we were born to be
and he urges um philip to never forget
what his name is
the name they share
and
they share a hug
and
this seems to convince philip and to
calm him down
so
i wanted to ask you about marco's
comments here about series
and
why he is making these comments is
interesting to me i think you can shed
more light on this
yeah i mean it's the
it's anything right um
any
any population is going to have natural
factions and
differences of opinions about certain
things i think with him bringing it up
here
he's trying to
do a little bit of damage control
because
as you mentioned as we've discussed it
does there is a good reason to do what
he did but
morally and then
just on the fact that
their stated purpose is to help belters
it kind of flies in the face of that
whenever you're doing the opposite right
and i think that you know when he says
i think that this idea don't never
forget what your name is the name that
we share
it's you know he's trying to
he's trying to
give him this
he's trying to pull on that on that
thing that is just
we're we're a part and you know we're
we're the only ones that can do this i
mean that's my take on it what did you
think
i think that's something that abusive
parents always you know bring up
we're family we share blood
that's why you know we got to stick
together that is just textbook a piece
of parenting i think
when you're yeah
when your child disagrees with you just
bring that up and
you know you win them over and it's that
easy i guess
yeah and i think that um we're going to
touch on this a little bit more i don't
want to get into it because of
what he has to do later but
i i definitely had something i wanted to
add there on that same line so i like
that that line of thought just let's put
that in the back of our minds and we'll
get to that in a minute
all right we are moving on to the tainan
and the inazami
the drummer and walker are discussing
the golden bow bough dissidents they're
teaming up with so you know they've got
some support now at least
and here michio is watching another news
feed we've got another one of those and
uh we
we won't go too much into this because
uh it's monica's propaganda basically
and we see pastor anna i think
and what did you think about her return
oh was it sad well it's
i mean
you know
it was not but
it was it was it was not it was it was
but it was awesome just the same you
know it's one of those things
when i saw it the first time i thought
okay well
that's better than nothing and then i i
read the i read something um that the
that they were saying that
i think it was tai he said that they
were hoping to involve like whenever
they found out it was only going to be
six episodes like they didn't have a
choice that's what they were getting
that there they had to start thinking
about things that they had to cut
and i think that there was an
implication that they had to cut some of
what they would have done with anna and
prax and bringing them back
and so yeah it felt like a bummer but it
was still it was still
i still had an emotional reaction
whenever i saw her on the screen and i
was glad that they were able to do at
least that because if not then you would
always say oh you know whatever happened
anna actually in the book babylon's
ashes she is
involved in the in the epilogue the
prologue in the epilogue
she doesn't play an active role during
the main part but
they do tie up the character to that
extent and
it's possible that there might still be
more i think
i don't have anything to say that for
sure but
um you know we'll we'll see what what
more they do with the
with these uh
the the propaganda as you refer to it
the um
the things that that she's monica's
doing to try to win over the belters but
yeah i will say this again when we talk
about prax but
it was a difficult time if one of these
actors was going to come into toronto
they would have to
i think at that time as far as i
understand it they would have had to
do a 14-day mandatory
um
my goodness
you know they would have had to
spend 14 days in quarantine before they
could even get into be on the set so if
it's a one day actor you're not going to
be able to have them involved in the in
the in the thing you know what i mean
yeah exactly and
uh
i think you know we can move on to the
main subject here which is um
drummer
getting more information about the
supply depots from walker
there may be
up to 10 of them that marco is hiding
i still
i still don't really know
why marco is keeping these i mean
from us today from a strategic
standpoint i get it you know he can
retreat to these points at
any time and
have his supplies
but
there must be another
reason for it i think maybe you know he
was planning this all along he was
planning to
leave series and
he wanted these supplies out there
but i'm looking for an ulterior motive
and i can't find it yet
i think as far as what they've said
in dialogue on screen
they're making it out that
there's something going on on medina
station and that takes priority over
everything else
like when i had that scene where he was
looking at the different supply depots
where they were located and looking at
getting supplies
as far as i can tell that is exactly
what they've said on like in the show
about what he's doing that for other
than that it's just speculation
i see
um michio and joseph get into a heated
discussion here about what's happening
on earth after they watch the news story
and joseph doesn't seem that sympathetic
and
he calls uh he says welcome to the belt
to uh the earthers because they now know
what the belters are going through every
single day i thought that was a nice
detail anything else to add on this
whole sequence
well it's you know that that's that goes
back to what abba sarala was saying in
the x-ray episode last week
she said we're all belters you know
and it's and it's why it's hard that's
why she went with that plan to try to
get monica to try to win some people
over
because it's a hard sell you're saying
you want us to feel bad for you because
you're in the same situation that we've
always been in
you know what i mean
yeah someone threw a rock at you but i
didn't do it
you know what i mean like i didn't sit
here and and and strap it to the back of
a ship and throw it at your thing you
know at your planet that's something
that happened
and yeah it sucks when you don't know
where your water and food's coming from
but how are you supposed to get that
much sympathy from someone who that's
just reality for so i thought that was
i thought that was a really good thing
to throw in there in an episode where
there's not a lot to do with drummer
and walker i mean it's funny because you
know he after they have the after they
have the falling out he says i can see
why you don't want that one on your ship
you know
and that's what i i put in my notes it's
like man he's making his lines count
isn't he he has at least one that he
barely says any words in this but it's
just a line that you can't help forget i
mean you can't forget because it's like
perfect for the situation so
definitely digging that character they
didn't have a lot to do in this episode
but it was nice that they
were able to touch on how belter's
experience what's experience what's
happening you know two that these two
are in a marriage together they're right
in this ship together all the time
and they have like a really different
reaction to it
okay uh do you think we can move on
yes
let's do it
all right let's touch on monica now um
she talks to alexarella about her
i'll call it propaganda piece but
uh new segment we could also call it
anyway mark is filming another one this
time at series and this time on series
and uh
tells the military to keep an eye on her
because she has a knack for causing
trouble
um and we see one of these uh soldiers
on series
who says didn't we come here to you know
shoot these people he is bloodthirsty he
wants war
and i think this guy on the left uh he's
the one who says that i think he might
be an mcrn soldier at first i think he's
i got it wrong in my in my recap i i was
thinking of them all as united you know
the united fleet but it's definitely
the guy on the right is the earther and
the guy on the left is a martian you can
tell by their um
by their suits
by their armor
yeah but the main thing here is that
we have the explosions and
turns out marco didn't just abandon
the station he also
either planted some bombs
or there were some people that were
still working for
marco there
or were maybe sympathetic to his cause
that wanted to hurt
the station at all costs because it is
now in the hands of the inners
uh this was i think a shocking moment
for me because
they all
when the soldiers went in and cleared
the area i thought you know this must be
clear that's all marco's got in his
hands but um
yeah this this explosion surprised me
what do you think
yeah i i was um
it's it's definitely
interesting and i think it it it's it
shows how difficult it is to hold any of
these stations in anywhere outside of
you know
where the anywhere in the belt really
you know is
the current conditions there's there's
always going to be some people there who
are
more sympathetic towards the free navy
than they are towards the inner planets
and so
it's a tricky situation
and i i didn't know if it was supposed
to be implied if this is something that
was
you know organic that happened after the
fact or if this was always part of
marco's plan
i thought it was kind of cool that you
saw
that
um you know some of the ships were
probably damaged they were like
corvettes that looked like the rossi and
then
you also saw this water
that was
you know such a such a valuable resource
you know and and there's so much of it
just going
you know just actually in here i
actually didn't notice that i thought it
was just um maybe air
but
this makes things
even more worrying because they only had
what three weeks of air and water
and if they use some of it to this
explosion
woof
yeah yeah no it's definitely it sped up
the ticking time bomb for sure
definitely made a big difference in what
what they have to deal with
and i think that that's really all we
need to say about that at this point
because like i said you don't know how
that i you know we had to figure out how
it was orchestrated i guess
and what the response will be
and we have the main event to get to
yeah
let's talk about it i don't want to take
too long to get there yeah let's talk
about the pella now because they
discover that cenante on his way to
series luckily the rossi was not at sea
on series when the bomb the bombs went
off
marco feels confident because they have
them out gunned it's three to one
and they have a missile advantage of
five to one so he feels like this is
as good a time as any to take them out
but um
rosenfeld doesn't feel that confident
because it is not
necessary
the the rossi in the grand scheme of
things is not
a massive threat to
the pela
and the three navy's overall plans
rosenfeld tries to be the voice of
reason but
that doesn't work that doesn't work on
marco and he orders everyone to their
battle station and then he asks phillip
to take the guns
um
philip accepts knowing full well that
they're planning to kill his mother's
ship with her in it
yeah i think this this was
just
a great move by marco you know from my
viewers perspective it was obviously
horrible for a father to do
but it tells us a lot about
marco and i think he tells us
a lot about philip as well because he
was willing to accept this role after
you know being hesitant throughout this
season about what his father was doing
he was ready to further was ready to
cross the line as well
what do you think about this um
old decision to go after
the rossi
yeah i think it's a tough day at work
when you have to go in and you know you
find out that your your your job for
that day is to kill your mom for sure
and i think this i think this you know
part of that's cruelty i think part of
that is just that you know he's a cruel
person and if somebody's got to do it
then
what you know
it's him that's fine i think it's a bit
of a test like you were saying that he
did have to accept this he didn't it was
an order but
of course he could you know
resist it so i think it's it's it's part
of his cruel nature it's part of it as a
test for to see him
you know
will he do it but there's also that
something there's like that
there's something about it that feels
like a point of no return for his son's
character you know what i mean it's like
if you cross this line for for marco's
cause
how can what can you really do after
that you can't really walk away at that
point i mean he's already been involved
in
the rocks
he's yeah
once you kill your mother
like christina christine in the comments
makes a great point about this she says
if philip kills his mom
marco owns philip as well i think that's
what i'm saying you know it's like once
he does that
he's his for life like he can make him
do anything at that point there's just
nothing that like what could he tell him
to do that's worse kill himself you know
what i mean
it's like
it's just it's just i think that i think
that you really like when i first
watched this i was like yeah that's
really cool how could he ask his son to
do it but it's one of those things that
if you think about it even a little
it's just
it's just wild like that situation i
mean you know all he did is grow up this
guy's son you know what i mean like it's
that's just that's his life that's where
he's at you know
yeah i mean
we definitely got that problem in the
real world as well
your family can determine a lot of
things about
how you'll grow up and
how you'll end up
yeah this is a great reminder of that
we've got another super chat i think you
want me to yeah we have
you can if you want yeah
tm martin thank you for another five
dollars
he says do you think bull disappeared
because he would have tr thrown off the
rossi crew dynamics with too many
earthers on board
i um
yeah i don't i don't know if that that's
the most important thing um
i think that
bull i think that fans
were trying to figure out how
they were gonna deal with alex and
bull made the most sense
i think that
that that that idea of him holding
alex's cup at the end that seemed like
it was foreshadowing that they would
bring him on board
but i think the way that it played out
they always wanted to bring bull back
they didn't know that alex was going to
be gone whenever they wrote the fifth
season so they always wanted to bring
him back and they had a role for him to
play and then i suppose they have a
choice
whenever they got to it
and i think that
if you're willing to say that holden can
pilot the ship
then i think it's the right choice not
to bring somebody else in there and
complicate that dynamic anymore
you know we've seen that they have a lot
going on inside the rossi since the
first episode
they're not really even through that yet
so
how would bull being there
like an outsider that wasn't involved in
any of the stuff that came before it how
would that make that situation better
and i think that's where for me it makes
sense not to bring him back into it for
that reason yeah having to get alex out
of there was already a tough challenge
and
writing in another character to be part
of the crew
i think that's just a step too far for
the writers it's just too difficult i
think that's
that's why they um chose not to
not to make bull a part of the crew and
i think they were right in that decision
yeah i i think that you know it was
it made sense uh
just
as
there has to be a pilot it made sense to
use him if that was the case but i think
that
it's okay that they did it the way that
they did it and yeah i think i don't
think he would i liked the character by
the end of the of last season i i didn't
have anything against him it would have
been fine if he was there i guess but i
think that it's better without him
because we can just focus on the people
that we're really invested in at this
point
exactly we have another super chat by
juan doe
thank you for the two heroes
do you want to get this one pete
marco intimidates philip sexually
yeah um all right then
what else can you say that's that's
really that's just
oh it says it all doesn't it
i think so too
i think we can move on to uh amos and
bobby now
before we continue with this pella
versus rossi confrontation
uh aims and bobby are continuing to bond
working on her armor
when amos gets a message from prax yes
pranks is back
and i i watched your breakdown when he
said you know he might have
he might have shot the scene from his
closet in his uh in his um home
yeah that was that was pretty funny and
i mean i think he might have done that
what do you think do you think that is
something there
probably i mean
why would he need to be somewhere else
to be honest
that's true yeah
and you know he doesn't wait just just
to throw it out there though some great
face acting from from his closet if
that's the case
i mean that guy he really made the most
out of what they gave him to do here i
mean really i'm not saying that to be
like facetious i think that
the way that he did the way that he
handled the call was was fantastic
indeed
i'm trying to remember if i've seen the
actor in something else but you know
let's not digress too much the guy is a
great actor i agree
um this
this message is about
a new strain of yeast that could create
massive amounts of food out of little
more
a lot of little out of little more than
spare carbon dioxide and waste energy
but this is obviously a massive game
changer
when the entire solar system is
struggling with food
this pranks fella has come up with
and his team has come up with
a
an incredible food source
that could be
crucial
in getting out of this crisis and
prax wants aimus to use his contacts to
you know to
i guess
share this data
and that's about it
what do you think about this
sequence pete
yeah i guess there's a couple of things
he you know this is something that they
are this is
he doesn't really go into it completely
here but
this is something this is one of those
things that they've figured out after
the introduction of the proto-molecule
like they learn some things like
sometimes
they have different kinds of um like for
the ship say they have different
composites that they can put together
after they study how the proto-molecule
does things and this is another
situation where
they can take something that was you
know useless and actually get a lot of
food out of it so
it is a huge thing for a planet that's
dying you know that's pretty obvious and
i think that the big takeaway from this
whole scene
is just that
he's doing this he's risking his family
he's risking his own safety i mean his
co-worker was killed because she was
trying to give this to the inner planets
and his reaction to that was to go and
take it and give it to the inner planet
so
amos has that realization where he says
you know there's nothing in this for him
he's just doing it because he's a good
guy and i i think that's a great ending
for a character
to have in this story considering that
they weren't able to bring him back but
i thought this worked really well
yeah it was also a great moment for amos
because he realizes
there's you know we've seen him this
season before asking how much they were
getting paid and how that wasn't enough
to chase you know marco he was wondering
why he was out here in the first place
but in this instance
he's doing this
or
he's doing this just to help out a
friend
and i think that's an important moment
for amos's development
absolutely and you know that that that
is that's a great take on that because
it seemed like i mean when amos was
saying those things when he was saying
are you getting paid more and all that
it didn't necessarily seem out of
character but it's not something that he
was always
concerned with
you know it wasn't a big part of his
character before
and then when you do when you see this
you see this rebel rebel uh revelation
that you just pointed out it really
makes that make sense doesn't it
exactly
and you know there was definitely that
that callback to their relationship and
how much fun that was to watch when he
says don't worry about me or may or the
rest of us i can take care of them
and then he just sort of ends with i
miss you my friend you know and it's
like
back then you're like wow amos can
actually have a friend you know you
don't even know if he's like
capable capable of those kinds of
relationships or whatever and see that
full come full circle it's it's a great
thing
and also in the meantime holden can't
get any sleep
i i liked it when
when naomi i think i think it was naomi
that
called holden to the desk and holden was
like i'm awake i'm awake and he just
he just showcases the stress holding his
under he can't even get
an hour of sleep in
and yeah naomi explains to him that
this um she was reviewing the bar keith
fletch and the other fuji the other
footage from other ships
it's like a hole opens up in in the
floor and if someone falls in then
they're gone but then a minute later the
hole itself is gone and everything seems
normal until another hole opens up
somewhere else
and then for the next minutes more
people fall into that
so this is what she figures out
i i don't think that's too much really
that's why i said earlier in the stream
that
i wasn't too excited about this because
we're not getting much progress
but
at least she's able to connect these
disappearances
yeah i i think
there's not really much i can say about
any of that um
like i said for the for the most part it
works as it's something for her to do at
this point
and you can understand why holden would
be obsessed with that
and kind of surprised that nobody else
is i think that's sort of one of the the
things that
comes out in this is that
all that stuff just happened yeah
there's a war going on but
there may be something bigger out there
that
could change things
significantly on top of all that you
know what i mean and
holden has that unique position where
he's still
haunted by what he's seen so you know
he's keeping it
in the story or whatever you know
all right ladies and gentlemen let's get
to the main event here
the three free navy ships are closing in
on the rossi
and the pella has a missile lug and
marco tells philip to take the shot
to
basically tell
philip to kill
his mother
and they fire it they fire a group of
missiles that the rossi is able to shoot
down with its pdcs and this whole
sequence i think was
done really well it excited me a lot i
had to rewatch it to you know pick up
more details
but
moving on holden decides to fire up the
railgun even though they're too far away
he does a quick turn which we classified
as
a 360 noscope and he fires a shot that
it's the lauber who didn't have time to
react so one of those
ships that we're with the free that they
were with marco
has taken damage
it is crippled it is venting it is
venting atmosphere and
so the other ship has to break off to
help them and marco's ship the pella is
alone
but marco
i guess um
he says he doesn't need either of them
he's just too confident
and
i think that was a positive that was a
puzzling moment i think
well to be fair technically the pella
does outmatch the rossi in every
you know every every metric that you
might be able to
put them against each other in like he's
he's not wrong
he he's not wrong but
they're the rossi here they apply a
technique that
nobody could really plan for
the one thing that they have is they
have this aftermarket
keel mounted rail gun that alex liked to
to bring up so much in the past you know
and then the books you hear them say it
about 10 000 times
they have this one thing and um
i'll let you get into
you know the rest of the the battle but
it it's
i i don't think marcum is making a
mistake whenever he thinks that the
pellets should be able to beat the rossi
one on one
it's it's more it's a newer
bigger faster ship that has more weapons
you know what i mean so it's like
he he's not wrong
yeah i mean i get that part but um he
went into this three to one and it's now
one-on-one no matter how
strong the pele is
that's still
you know that still has diminished um
their chances
and right you know this is not
a crucial this is not a crucial mission
either so
no and that's really that that that's
really the chain reaction that happens
here you brought it up that rosenfeld
you know doesn't wasn't on board for it
and she was right
there really is no thing there's nothing
about
destroying the rossi that makes sense
now that he's in the fight though
it's pretty hard to imagine that he
would run away
because one of his other i mean you
could i guess you could say well he
would be able to say it wasn't his fault
it was their fault or whatever but
yeah i mean
this is all happening you know
right this all happens in what a couple
of minutes total so it's not like
there's a lot of deep thinking going on
here it's a lot of uh
chase and
heat of the moment type stuff right
yeah that's that's true
um the rossi takes damage uh after a
little bit of an exchange
and ames and clarissa are trying to
repair these there's a great there's a
great moment here
where amos tells peaches that's that's
the job even when they're taking fire
they have to fix stuff
and
while you know everything seems lost for
the rossi when they're in a tough spot
bobby comes up to assess the situation
and
when holden fires again she notices that
the pellet dodges the same exact way
each time so she notices a pattern
and i definitely did not pick this up
the first time i watched it
and this is how
you know the rossi is able to
outmaneuver
the pellet it tells hold on to fire
torpedoes to give them something
different to worry about
and to keep to give her pdc control
and when
jim fires the torpedoes she fires a
burst of ptc rounds to where they will
dodge
so because she knows the pattern she
knows where the pellet will be
and they fire the railgun again
in that exact spot even though the spot
at first is empty
you see them moving through space
looking almost like a misfire since they
aimed at nothing like we said
and when the pellet dives again they fly
right into
the rounds and
the pellet is knocked out temporarily
this is where i wanted to ask you about
how this was portrayed in the books
because
it was like i said it was difficult to
pick up in
real time when i was watching it
i couldn't really figure out what bobby
saw
i had to pause and then go back
so how was this scene different or was
it the same in the books
well it was it was it was completely
like the actual
the the
the way they the way they killed the
pella and or the way they disabled the
pellet i guess because it does is able
to go
away and the in the whole the whole rail
gun
using the rail gun that that that's all
the same but everything else about it is
completely different in the books like
it it really
it it's it's long it's drawn out
people are there's like way more people
on the rossi because fred johnson
they're they're transporting fred
johnson two series
from tycho to series
and he has a whole crew with him so it's
like holden isn't doing anything in the
book like he's sitting around thinking i
wish i had something to do because
he's not he's not involved in the battle
at all
he's basically just trying not to stroke
out because they're doing this flip and
burn that is crazy that i i guess you
kind of see that in the show but it's
not
like
it didn't really feel like they were
dying or they might die as a result of
what they the maneuver it seemed more
like hey this is this cool thing we can
do we'll just whip the ship around and
fire and then go back to it you know
what i mean
and it's not to say that it's bad in the
show it's it's actually like we had a
conversation earlier it is one of the
best uh
battle scenes it's just uh it's just the
adaptation it's it's a lot different
and the one part that was missing for me
was
just that
the
the way that she figured it the way that
bobby figured it out it seemed a lot
more impressive in the book it seemed
like
it took some it was a puzzle she was
trying to solve a puzzle
here it's sort of like you know it just
felt like something that anyone in her
position might do
and the books it seemed like this was
some kind of amazing
discovery that maybe nobody would have
ever thought of and that is just like so
brilliant you know what i mean
but the thing is is that the the the
pella but all of these ships they use a
ton of ai to do everything
so the the the idea here is that
they're using the ships dodging they
know it turns so they know there's going
to be a railgun
round coming their way so they have they
you know there's a there's a the the
computer is helping them fly the ship
and because of that it's doing the same
thing in a
pattern that they can actually
anticipate
and so yeah like you said she sends
these shots out that look like they're
going nowhere that there's really no
reason that they would notice
they're just floating in a straight line
in space to a point where they are going
to try to make the pellet be later and
those two things come together perfectly
and then it gets killed for the time
being
yeah and this that is when
bobby is ready to take the kill shot and
end the free navy's reign by killing
marco
but
holden wants to try to take marco
prisoner
naomi points out that marco will never
surrender
but holden
says if it doesn't work bobby can take
the shot so it doesn't hurt doesn't hurt
to try
uh when he pulls up to calm and asks
marco to give up
which which of course he won't do
the
marco moves aside so that they can see
philippe he does this intentionally
there's like almost a slide by marco and
i also like the way marco greeted james
you know
he only said uh jim holden
holden's name he said james holden but
you know that delivery by marco was
exquisite
yeah and and the look and the and the
actual look on his face that he holds
there as he's sitting there it it look i
mean i felt like i was there i felt like
this was a real thing that was happening
you know what i mean like yeah he was
these are two men
the one on the other end they're gonna
die really soon as far as they know you
know what i mean
exactly and he's put it on a face
because
he knows that people are watching him
in his last moments and this is the face
that he's going to present
in that situation
no begging no asking for
mercy
nothing just look at my face look at who
i am
i'm right here oh yeah you know my son
he's right here too he's right behind me
let me step over to the side here so
that you can see
oh it was great it's such a great it's
such a great thing it's it's it it
happens in the books is it's slightly
different um
like i said holden isn't doing he's not
doing anything in the battle he's not
flying the ship he's not commanding he's
just sitting there you know getting
crushed by the the high g
and so bobby sends him a message to
distract them
and that's what he comes up with is that
he he calls them on a tight beam or
whatever but
in the thing and there he's he's sort of
marco just sort of changes it so that
they can only see philip in the last
moments and it feels like he's actually
doing that to try to
maybe get them to think twice about
killing
the ship you know killing him in the
show i thought they made him seem a lot
more cavalier and
i just thought it was a great
look you know for that that scene right
there
yeah marco does that by saying that he
will die before he lives at the end of
their leash
and that's that's when bobby takes the
shot
she realizes marcus not gonna
surrender
when everyone including naomi watches
them on
as the torpedo approaches to kill them
so it seems like this is a done deal but
the warhead does not detonate
and the palace drive comes back online
the pallet disengages on marco's command
and they leave
amos comes in and asks if they won and
bobby says
not but bob says no but at least they
didn't lose
and
at the last moment so in the last
moments of the episode we see holden
doing something while um
the missile was approaching
and on his heads-up display we learned
that he disarmed the torpedo and let
them live so
this is pretty much on brand for holden
because he's not a killer
and he knew that
he knew that letting philip die in
killing phillips on purpose
would break naomi and i guess that's why
he didn't kill them i don't agree with
it um on a strategic standpoint but from
a strategic sense but
from an emotional standpoint it made
sense for holden what do you think
yeah i think it's i think it's just one
of those things you know you could try
to make sense of it you can try to
figure it out you can try to follow what
we know about the character everything
that led up to this moment
but i think the reality is is this is a
situation where he saw naomi's kid
the kid looks like naomi
you know what i mean he saw her face in
this child's face and he had only a few
seconds and he made an irrational
decision
and that's the kind of thing people do
that's the kind of thing that
everyone does on a daily basis
and the difference here is there are
some real stakes it's not just
the people that are on this ship that
would have won the battle it's like
lots of other people that are unrelated
might die as a result of this decision
and
also in the internal dynamics he's
thinking for naomi you know what i mean
like that is just not necessarily his
job especially not in this position
right here
she didn't make a plea to stop it
he did it for her in a way that isn't
necessarily
sensible or or even you know it's hard
to back it up after the fact but like i
said i think you have to look at this as
just
what it is it's a person
having an emotional response to
something and then making a decision and
in this case
quite an irrational one
and
you know
it's
it'll be interesting to see how it goes
from there right
yeah and
it could also be
that um
all in one didn't want to make a martyr
out of marco
i think that could be the case as well
but you know how how else are you gonna
end the war
he has to be killed at some point
because he's not going to surrender
maybe yeah i think
i i did see sorry to interrupt but i did
see a lot of people add that in there
you know like that that whenever they're
trying to
kind of get past the cog like the the
dissonance that's involved there you
know what i mean but
i don't think that's the case i mean i
think that he just saw saw this person
that that's he thinks is a part of a
person that he loves
and he had an emotional response and
yeah after the fact you could say well i
didn't want to make him a martyr but
like you've just said
you as you were saying that you know you
provided the answer to why that's a
terrible idea
he's gonna die anyways
killing him
killing him today or tomorrow or any
other day he's still going to be a
martyr for some people
in this case he's dead and nobody else
dies and i mean that's just the reality
of it right
and i also wonder how
jim's gonna feel if
you know the free navy and marco's uh
upcoming plans
which we'll talk about in a minute
hurts i don't know thousands of people
hundreds of thousands of people millions
of people i'm not sure
if that happens what kind of a toll is
that gonna take on jim's conscience
maybe he'll feel like he could have
prevented that
so this is definitely this is definitely
a very consequential decision by jim
absolutely there's real stakes like i
said it's not it's it's a thing that
people do you know i'll probably do this
today at some point i'll probably
have to make a decision my emotions will
factor into it but there'll be zero
stakes involved you know what i mean
like it'll be like
not nobody's gonna die because of any
decision i make you know so i think that
that's really
i i i find it horribly frustrating that
he decided to do this you know what i
mean don't don't get me wrong i don't
want to say that
but i think that that is
what makes it
makes sense in like why it's why it's a
great thing to add to the story is that
you know
and he's it it does it
holden's on a big you know we know how
holden was in the beginning
in book six i you know this as far as
just like big picture stuff for me big
book six was where
you know in book five you had he had him
separated from the rest of the crew and
he had to kind of look at himself and
where he was at and
he really had a new appreciation for how
important this family that he's brought
together is for him and how much he
needs that you know i don't know if the
show conveyed that as well as the book
does probably not but
it's there you know what i mean so like
that was his whole
revelation at the end of
of the fifth book was that man these
people are my family and i need them and
i'm much better when they're here
and so
you know you see him changing here and
the thing about book six is like it it
redefines him as a character
this is part of that and you know it
continues from here but
i think that
in the books you know he did the same
thing in the books this isn't a show
only thing
it played out a lot differently though
because
fred dies during this battle
you know what i mean so he's
nobody's thinking about whether he
turned off the the
like he deactivated the torpedoes or not
they're thinking oh my god fred is dying
you know what i mean so they're dealing
with that
they're just happy to get out of this
situation alive
and then it comes up later you know what
i mean and
here it's really front and center
like you you if even if you hadn't
thought about it before you know now
that
you see it at the end of this episode
there's no way that this doesn't get
brought up again right exactly
they they released a little teaser today
where they kind of showed a little bit
of that i won't get into it here but i
guess i'll i'll talk about that in my
next video
it's it's an interesting situation
and before we we move on from that i
just wanted to thank dana pearson for
the
super chat
and um
he says he loves the format i i actually
like doing this format i appreciate that
you guys are here and you're
watching
hopefully by the time we get to the end
of the season we'll have it down and
it'll be um
you know something that we can
do in the future with different shows
agreed and i think we can move on to
the end of the episode
where
marco is furious that they lost and he
tells philip he failed in front of
everyone so he shifts the blame to
philip
this was
just
incredibly hard to watch
from marco's perspective
but it was satisfying to watch because
philip turns it around and says it's
marco's fault because they didn't need
to go after the rasanante in the first
place and he's 100 right
he blames he blames marco's pride and
challenges his authority in front of the
whole crew
and that's when marco calls philip a
coward
he cuts him off and relieves him of duty
marco tells philip to get off of the
deck and out of his sight
and
yeah like i said phillip was entirely
correct because the rosenfeld
rosenfeld warned
marco that they shouldn't go after the
rossi
what do you think because
i didn't expect philip to go
go face to face with his father in front
of everybody after you know getting on
his side
but
when marco tried to blame fella for us
i think that was the natural reaction i
mean marco had it coming i mean
that's what i think
yeah absolutely um
there was no reason to do it
he sees here that
it's an unforced error it makes him look
terrible in front of everybody
and he looks for a way to shift the
blame onto
his son
and really it's not even
i don't know if he was explicitly doing
that or if it just comes out that way
because philip's ready to explode or
whatever
philip was on the guns he didn't really
do anything wrong so i don't even think
that's the
you know i don't think he's saying that
in in in the direct sense i think it's
more of just like
if he had a better crew
this would have went better you know
what i mean
yeah and and it really comes down to
what isaiah morris says in that quote
there it's
if things don't go right it must be
somebody else's fault because it's not
his when you know obviously it's plain
and
like i said philip goes through a big
journey in this episode because this is
a thing
that
even though he was pulled closer to his
father earlier in the episode
it's how can he reconcile these two
things here you know what i mean like
his father says we need to be together
and then
just a couple of hours later he tells
him he's a coward
and get out of my sight you know what i
mean so it's
it's a messed up situation he's he has
nowhere to go with this at all right
yeah and i don't think he's gonna get on
marcus good side now because
this is not the first outburst this is
not the first out person philip has had
and
marco
i think decided to let it go let what
happened on series go when philip killed
his friend
but um challenging challenging him like
that in front of the whole crew
just isn't something they can
you know
they can't move past that i think this
is a turning point like you said
um yeah and i'm looking at the chat and
uh they're saying
people are saying that they thought that
that was implied that
he didn't do a thorough job i i didn't
take that away from it i don't know is
that what you thought
benjamin
i'm not i'm not really sure i mean
like you said the only thing philip did
was to fire the weapons and
as far as i know is he aiming himself
or is he just pressing a button and the
ai is taking care of the
locking procedure
yeah i i don't i mean i don't want to
get into the details of all of that i
don't know for sure
but i think marco is the captain he
wasn't he wasn't
he wasn't opposed to it until he lost
you know what i mean yeah he does he
wasn't making any corrections or doing
anything at all he it seemed like as far
as what we were watching
that he was doing the job that was
presented for him and
really what it comes down to is whoever
was piloting is using that
ai to
dodge and they figured it out that it
was a pattern
i mean the rossi was being
slowly beaten down wasn't it i mean they
were the pdc they were losing control of
the pdcs and
it was a dire situation if they didn't
if they didn't figure out what they did
they were losing
yeah exactly and that's why you know
philip was right to
point that out
he didn't do anything wrong
so you know i don't get that
i don't understand that suggestion from
uh the chat uh i don't understand that
yeah i mean i'm not a military
strategist or someone whoever
you know
i can't say what the different people on
on a spaceship do at their at their post
you know what i mean except for what
i've read in the books and the way that
it came down
and you know from that reading of it i
didn't get the idea that
philip had done anything wrong or even
did anything that someone else wouldn't
do exactly the same if they were in his
seat but you know i could be wrong
okay i think that that about covers it
for that part i think we can get to
i think the most
juicy part of the episode because
marco gets a message from medina station
they say
they're pleased to report that
g6 was just received at
laconia ringgate
operational testing will commence as
soon as possible and they will of course
keep you keep marco fully apprised
they say if this one performs as well as
the others it will be fun and we see
that what they're talking about on the
screen
if you can bring that up pete
yeah yeah
this one
uh
i think we discussed this earlier
because you know you can't really talk
that much about this because you've read
the books you know what it is but for me
this doesn't look like
a ship because ships like in the ships
in the expanse universe doesn't really
they don't really look like this so i
don't think this one is a ship i said
i said to you that it looks more like a
weapon maybe that they can
that they can
plant on something
and but i'm still you know theorizing
here i i don't have any clue what's
going on
but i just noticed that it doesn't have
a drive plume that that the the ships
usually have that's why i have that
theory
i think it's a weapon
yeah i i like yeah like you said i can't
really comment too much on it but i
would just add that having read the
books and knowing what's going on there
i was still a little bit confused
whenever i saw these
scenes because
there was mention of the installation
they were having problems with
installation from things that they were
getting from laconia that was rosenfeld
told um
marco that and epis a couple episodes
ago
and so that yeah that part is clear
right there something's coming from
laconia
and this feels like it's going to
strengthen his position
yeah you see a little
as far as the dry plume you see it's
actually a bunch of little torch drives
like those little um
those little tugs that they used like
when we saw them
recover the behemoth
after
after you know when it was the naboo and
it was sent after eros and things like
that you know what i mean
it looks like they're moving this thing
that way
but a lot of people saw this and they
thought that it was a ship so
it's hard to say you know what i mean
like i that's the part i was like when i
watched it the first time i knew what
they were delivering or whatever and and
and i wasn't exactly sure what they were
showing us
what's happening
here because
the thing about the the medina storyline
is that it's just
it's just been cut from the show it's
been it's been presented as a mystery
like we don't know what's going on there
whereas in the books there's different
characters and it's still a mystery in
the sense that it doesn't follow one
point of view character it bounces from
one every chapter it's a different one
so the different people are putting the
story together
so i guess here you know we're having
that same kind of experience of like we
know something's going on there but we
don't know what it is
and i mean like i said before i think
that what you're saying that sounds like
a reasonable
uh conclusion to come to i don't know
what people are saying in in the chat if
they are
thinking about one of them
one of them makes a lot of sense but
maybe people don't want to people don't
want to hear it because
it sounds like it's right
because the initials spell something out
and one of our commenters
i think figured something out i see that
now too
it's uh yeah like i said in the in in
the recap
that is something that could help you
put it together
the rsrg
and and also the opening credits scene
there is you know there's been something
that's been changing in that every week
and it kind of maybe would help you
figure out how that works
yeah but taking a step back i i think um
marco's end goal here is to
control the ring gates rather than the
belt stations themselves and he's made
it clear that he doesn't really care
that much about certain stations
he doesn't care a lot about the belter
people either
and maybe you know controlling
controlling the ring gates is his
ultimate goal that's what he's been
trying to figure out this whole time how
he could
constantly defend them and maybe these
uh
these shipments they're talking about
are weapons to
take control of the ring aids i mean
they they have control i think but
to um
to retain control i suppose
yeah and it kind of comes back to that
soviet er
whenever soviet era was having that
speech in last season where he was
talking about how you could control
the choke point at the ring
how it's you know it's definitely
something that if you could
if you could set it up correctly then
you could control all traffic through
there
with a spread you know a pretty small
force could control
that tr you know that being able to go
through there or not
against
a very large force you know what i mean
so
it's something to think about for
a place for him to
you know
by proximity it's way out there in space
right so he can
he can always fall back to that if he
needs to or whatever and you know yeah i
think it does
i think that
what you said is true he doesn't really
care about all the other stations and
the people at least that's what he's
showing us right but there's also a
there's definitely a strategic
reason for him to focus on the ring
regardless even if he does care about
those people and he does care about the
other stations that's one of the
takeaways from season five is how
important that um the slow zone really
is right
yeah and like you said
even if he cares about the belted people
he would want to control
the
the ring yet because
this may maybe this would allow the
belter people to
have
have a
have an actual planet to live on
that might be their future because the
solar system is
from what it looks like on the show
the solar system is dying out
everybody's becoming belters it's not a
like it's not a life you want to live
really
yeah and there's there's just a couple
of things to keep in mind when you think
about that the first is um
the idea that earth is dying
but the
the thing about it is is that you know
all these other planets exist but you
still need that that's part of what
we're seeing on laconia right they can't
go to laconia and just
plant a garden and eat the food and the
plants and the animals that are already
there
all of that is it doesn't it doesn't
mesh with our chemistry our you know way
we way we evolved in the way things
evolved there is incompatible
so
that whole thing with um you know
being able to control all those worlds
is one thing but you you still have
they're still
they're still tethered to earth for
certain things no matter what because
that's where we came from right yeah
that makes sense so
yeah so that's one thing to think about
like you can't just shut down the soul
you can't just shut down soul ring or
you know if it's possible i don't even
know but to to destroy it in some way
and just go okay we're gonna hang out in
these other places you know what i'm
saying yeah you can't just civilize
civilization can't just move on
without earth at all you know what i
mean
yeah that's true
yeah so there's there's that to think
about but
controlling that is huge because there's
there's a ton of resources there and
there's
that's that's really power for them in a
way that they wouldn't have otherwise
because they could never
negotiate
with the power that controlled the belt
before the corporations and
the governments that were
you know on their side because they were
relying on their their them for their
resources and that income and everything
else so
it's it's a
it's a pretty cool it's a pretty cool
setup for the last
half of the season i think
yeah and as we start to give our final
thoughts on the episode i think people
can start uh sending their questions
yeah if you guys have questions
yeah we can start looking for those
yeah so i think i think we were in
agreement that this is probably the best
episode so far this season
easily see episode two and episode three
were a pretty good one-two punch it's
sort of
kind of like the low stakes
battle with the azure dragon
comparatively you know what i mean like
he kind of felt like they were going to
win that one
because of bobby and her her skills and
because you know there wasn't uh the
same kind of thing and then
this time we get the you know the one
that you feel like they might actually
lose if it wasn't a tv show and they
weren't the stars right
yeah exactly and you know
having marco talk to holden
that scene was
just exquisite you know there was
nothing like that in episode two or
episode one so that's what sets episode
three apart
what clarissa you mean
no
uh sorry i i wanted to say marco and
holden
um
coming face to face
even though it's through a screen
uh that moment was just incredible you
know the way like you said the way
marco just said
just send him james holden he was just
chilling so i think this was the best
episode of the season so far and this is
when i stopped watching the screeners
because
i didn't want to i didn't want to just
um finish the whole season in one
sitting
we had access to all six episodes you
know but um i stopped at episode three
because
i wanted to
i guess
prolong my enjoyment of the show
now i decided to watch week to week
uh but yeah i think this was um the best
episode of the season so far it was
probably you know one of the best
episodes since the show went over when i
went over to amazon
to be perfectly honest
i think that's a i think that's
definitely fair
i would say that
uh yeah
i like i said i i kind of hate ranking
things because of the recency of it all
but
it was definitely a solid episode i i i
don't
i can't think of anything that i didn't
like about it
you know it was pretty much start to
finish everything was awesome all the
way through
i had this question i pulled up here
they someone i keep hearing this a lot
you know people are curious as to the
point of the laconia stuff
if this is the end
it's taking up a lot of time
uh
in the episode and we talked about this
a little bit last week
and i i think that
it's i think it's not an easy question
to answer the
i i made a video about this before the
season came out before i saw any any of
it and just like why i thought they were
doing it and that turned out to be
right i think i think i i had the idea
that i think that got to the idea that i
would say here and it's that
this is
it's it's more important
story-wise the laconia stuff is more
important towards the end
it does though tie into what's happening
now it does provide some answers as to
where those people went out when the way
at the end of last season those martian
martians who went through the ring
and i think that
there is a payoff as far as the regular
stories concerned
but i think the big thing about the
laconia stuff is that
it shows us
what
i mean they can't end the proto-molecule
story in
this
sixth season they couldn't do that they
have three
really great detailed books that are
have a lot of different progression
towards getting to that answer
and
i think whenever that's the case there's
no way that they could have wrapped that
up i think what you need to do then is
you have to ask the question what are
people going to do
with this thing
you know this this proto-molecule thing
that drove so much of the story
early on
you have to address like you can't just
say it doesn't exist in this part of the
story so we're not going to bring it up
but what lacunae it does is it shows a
group of people who are still trying to
utilize the proto-molecule
to their advantage
and so you know i can't really say
anything else beyond that because of
spoilers but i think that's the reason
why it works and
i i like i said we talked about this
last week i feel like i understand
when people say that it's taking up time
from the main story because it is
literally doing that you know
yeah but
it's but i think that if they just
didn't address the proto-molecule at all
that would probably be much worse don't
you think
yeah exactly and i i kind of got that
sentiment
up until episode three but uh what we
saw here with the strange dog fixing a
living thing and a drone
i think that makes
this storyline a lot more interesting
i i
i wondered about the point of
the laconia stuff up until episode three
but now
it seems pretty crucial for
the future of the universe i mean
if the strange dog is as powerful as it
seems
yeah and and that's the thing i mean
this is a
something that's going on there is
related to the fact that they brought
the proto-molecule through the ring gate
at the end of the season
you know remember
you remember the fun in the finale abba
sarala says why would they take the
proto-molecule there at knowing what
happened on illus and
they're taking it there because they
know what happened on ellis they want to
see what they can do with it you know
what i mean
yeah and
we know that that's heavily implied at
this point and so now we're starting to
see that
what's what might go
what might happen what might go right
what might go wrong you know what i mean
they have cortisol he is the man who
knows
as much about it as anyone does right
it's not like they're just going in
blind not knowing they have it but
you know it's an interesting thing and
we got another question does it feel
that the proto-molecule is left out of
the plot for so long in the books too
and yeah absolutely it's this is a
pretty one-to-one adaptation
in that regard
um
that's the actually there's more
proto-molecule in season six than there
is in book six because they're adding
strange dogs strange dogs is a novella
it's not part of the regular story
it's uh
once once the first part of like if you
think of the books they're they're
they're they're broken up into like one
and two to go together
three and four go together and five and
six go together
and then the last three are a trilogy so
the
in five and six it takes the
protomolecule takes a back seat because
its existence made it possible for this
breakaway fleet to
take off from mars whenever it started
falling apart
and
it gave us it it created a situation
where a guy like marco could really
actually
cause problems for the
status quo for the way that things have
always been inside the inner planets
and a war broke out and they have to
deal with that so
that yeah that part isn't different at
all between books to show
yeah and from what it sounds like it
does make a lot of sense in the grand
scheme of things
so
yeah it's not ideal because you know you
don't get to see those you know there's
no guarantee that we'll get to see that
trilogy as tv show or movies or whatever
but
i mean it's a you know it's the
it's the natural progression of the
story they they started out
telling us a story about
the relations between the three
different factions inside the inner
planets before there was rings and
you know before there was the
possibility of going to all these places
so i guess you know they they have to
tie that up before they can move on to
that next level of the story
gina bonina asks if bobby is flirting
with amos
uh i see i have seen a lot of people say
that
a lot of people thought that that was
that was happening
because i read the books and i know the
characters it wasn't something that
crossed my mind i thought like there was
playfulness
i thought it was more oh i interpreted
it more as like
these are two badasses that are testing
each other a little bit
more than um you know this is a man and
a woman that are checking each other out
or whatever but
they that they have chemistry that
part's for sure you know what i mean
like i i can see where you would come up
with that
what did you think i can't remember what
you said
yeah last week i said um i think i
brought this point up last week and
i definitely felt like there was some
some tension there let's say but
i don't think it i think it was just um
the writers
you know basically winking at us just um
just having a bit of fun i don't think
it's gonna
actually turn into a real relationship
or anything
so yeah i i think
i mean
i i i think they probably wanted to have
it have it be playful and it is there's
flirting like actual flirting but i
don't know if it's supposed to be that
you think that maybe they're going to be
a love interest or whatever you know
what i mean
i wanted to i wanted to i meant to say
something about this at the beginning so
i always wanted to pull up this question
here will there be a sequel as rumored
there was a thing going around where
um i saw in the comments after i put out
my last video that people said oh i saw
online that they're they're doing
another season and a movie and
that
tai and the the official uh james essay
corey account
did debunk that he said that that was
completely made up there was nothing of
substance that that article was based on
and
he would know you know what i mean like
i started here
like i said it was down the stream
like i said earlier in the stream the
internet is the most trustworthy
place
in this whole world
believe everything you see don't don't
believe pete or ty
i'm just i'm just kidding
just
just the internet it's definitely right
yeah
i wish i wish it was true though i mean
yeah absolutely i
i don't know i think that um
i i used to think
that it was for sure going to happen
like it was inevitable
as we've gotten closer to the actual end
i i don't know that
i just i feel like we would have already
heard about it now or we would by the
you know like i guess what one of the
things that i really held on to was the
idea that
there was a couple of interviews with
um
with the the writers uh daniel and ty
and then there was a couple with the
actors
especially wes and dominique they did a
couple right around season five that
made it seem like they knew something
was gonna happen
and they just couldn't say it you know
and i don't i don't feel that that is
i i don't that doesn't really give me
hope anymore i think that was just me
seeing what i wanted to see
i think that it would be pretty
surprising if if
such a successful thing and we talked
about this last week so i don't want to
go
on about it too much but you know i
i think it's surprising that something
that's this good and that is
complete
and that people already like it it's
kind of surprising that they wouldn't
make that somebody wouldn't make that
but
i don't think there's any plans to do it
right now the amazing jennifer says
wonder how much it would be to
crowdsource expense and
i want to say that
one person a single person can
crowdsource the expansive no the rest
the rest of the expense all three
seasons
and his name
he claims to be a fan his name is jeff
bezos
if you want to crowdsource the expense
go ahead man come on
but you know seriously
we can't we can't crouch crouchers at
the expense i mean
that would be insane
yeah the way that this is going to come
back is if somebody like some producers
get together and they have hundreds of
millions of dollars that they need to
throw at something and it's the right
place at the right time that it's there
you know what i mean
you are talking about hundreds of
millions and i think that
something that that to keep in mind is
something that came up before around
this time in season five was that
amazon has these exclusives streaming
rights to the whole series for a period
of time and then those rights go back to
alcon
you know what i mean
nobody's probably going to pick it up
until they get those rights back because
you wouldn't want to have like say if
you were apple tv you wouldn't want to
bring out this show
that has season 7 coming soon and if you
want to watch the other six seasons go
over to amazon and watch them there
first and then come back to our platform
it's you know like that's not how that
works right
yeah and
do you know how you know how many years
they've got the expense for
uh explicitly it i think the way that he
said it
um i think they said that it was
a couple of years i think is the way the
quote went
but
that would be interesting i don't think
they had specifics but i i that's the
way that i i took it it was like maybe
like two or three more years until they
they went back up and then
you know you see you see shows like this
they bounce around to where they're
streaming all the time same with movies
you know
yeah and
motop asks is it not making money the
production value is better than anything
else out there it's almost like they
spend too much and i just wanted to say
that
this is one of the more frustrating
things with streaming because we don't
get any reliable numbers about how many
people watch
certain shows or movies
you know tv has that advantage you can
see you can actually see the ratings and
if the ratings are good your advertisers
are going to pay well
and the show's going to live on
but with streaming this is a problem
yeah and it makes it almost impossible
to understand like the metrics aren't
really about money it's about bringing
people in and having them subscribe not
advertise advertisers like you said
right
it's a pretty cut and dry process if
it's a network tv show or a cable show
if people aren't paying to put ads on
there then they can't afford to actually
produce it anymore or they could put
something else in that slot that would
earn better
here you're looking at like
a streaming service they want to show
that's going to get people who never
signed up before to come and sign up for
their thing you know for that and how do
you even really cover that you know what
i mean you pay attention to the first
thing someone watches
when they sign up
it's really just like i mean i'm sure
they have a good way of doing it because
that's like
you know that that's
why they exist or whatever but like it's
really hard for us as as viewers as
people are just like consuming the thing
to tell if it's successful or not like
obviously it's popular
compared to other things in that same
genre
but the question is more of like is it
doing the thing for the streaming
service that they want it to do
more than is it entertaining people
right
yeah
agreed and
the amazing jennifer
with another question says is this a new
format for pete i think you can answer
that one pete
like the stream is that what the
question is
yeah this is this is our second one
hopefully we did a little bit better
this time and
next week we'll do number three and
hopefully that'll go a little bit
smoother still
i think um
i think this is a good as it is a good
time as any to wrap things up pete it's
getting pretty yeah we're gonna have to
we're gonna
yeah definitely um i
just was reading this reading these last
couple ones i just wanted to thank
everybody for
participating and
sorry that i can't
look at everything i'm still trying to
sort this out
i felt a lot better this time than i did
last time so
i'm going to continue to try to get
better at that try to watch the
the chat while we're going but it's it's
great to see people coming and it's been
it's great to have the opportunity to
talk about this stuff more because
i tried to do a pretty tight recap and
you know hit the important parts but
i don't you know i can't i can't make
those an hour long because
it just it takes so long to edit
together so
it's nice to have a chance to um
you know see what you guys are saying
like i read all the comments before i
come in here and then
have someone to talk about it with and
dig into
the more interesting stuff in a way so
thanks a lot for coming out and thanks
for helping out benji do you want to say
anything before we go
yeah no problem pete it's it's good to
be here and i think we'll do three more
of these before the season ends so i'm
really excited about those
you can check out my channel
over at uh banjo tv
my name is uh should be written
something
somewhere around here is it not i'm not
sure but
it's benjamin tv
i cover some
shows on my channel including the
expanse but i'm only gonna cover episode
6 of the season
i started covering 1883 recently as
that's a western drama that came out
recently
and
yeah that's about it
thank you for
coming out guys and
joining the stream it's been fun
yep and um yeah you're there's there's a
there's a sub link in the description so
check that out and
hopefully you'll all be able to come
back the one thing i did want to mention
is we are thinking about maybe moving
this to saturday it's been the holidays
so we haven't been able to
pin down when the best time would do to
do it would be it would be um
a little bit earlier in the week so
after i close this out just mention in
the comments if you think that would be
a good idea as far as instead of doing
it on what is monday night on the east
coast if we did that
a couple of days earlier or something
like that just let us know what you
think would be the best time
and once again thanks for coming out
thanks for listening to us talk and
contributing here in the chat and we'll
talk to you soon